some 300 000 people living in pekilongan
central java face seeing their coastal
city submerged by ocean waves within 10
to 15 years that's due to a combination
of climate change bringing storms and
floods and a phenomenon called
subsidence it's a word that more and
more people have come to know as the
world continues to draw down our fresh
water sources subsidence is when the
ground beneath you sinks and it sinks
when we pump groundwater in aquifers far
below the surface that have been around
sometimes for thousands of years
that's what's happening along parts of
java's north coast here's our closer
look
the village of cement in the northern
city of pekalangan is slowly sinking
more than 40 families have already moved
away
but dozens others are holding on
this disaster is man-made and serves as
a warning sign to the entire northern
coast of java
here sea water levels have been steadily
increasing since 2005.
now they've begun to submerge villages
each morning in seminet sea water floods
into this house
little donna and his mum need to wait
for the water to recede
she will then dry the house before
bringing donna to school
but sometimes swimming is the only
option
if the roads are flooded he can't go to
school which way can we go if you do
that you would fall into the abyss
this morning dana can leave the house as
the sea receded quite quickly
along the path to school scars left by
the salt water can be seen everywhere
it's damaged properties and roads
it's dangerous for villagers to move
around especially when water levels are
high
[Applause]
sometimes they're big grand tides then
you can't go through the street the
waves are too big
climate change is one of the factors why
the village is sinking under the sea
forecasts show picalongan will
eventually submerge due to sea level
rise
but the northern coast of java is known
for its soft soil foundation
where this layer of soil stretches the
land is also sinking
has a young sedimentary soil
which will naturally experience
compression along with the lack of water
content in the soil
this problem has been worsened by the
pumping of groundwater for clean water
sanitation and industrial needs
picalongan's economic growth has been
dependent on groundwater since the 1900s
when indonesia was still under dutch
colonial rule
the colonial government built water
infrastructures along the so-called
sugar belt in northern java for the
cultivation of sugar cane
[Music]
water is taken from rivers and flows to
various corners
this ease of access to water encourages
industrialization and population growth
according to organization water
footprint
water consumption in industries is
especially high if products are mass
produced unsustainably
experts call it an exploitation of water
resources
requires large amounts of water
for rice
fishing
hospitality
of which must be taken from the ground
because water provided by the local
government is not sufficient
that causes natural aquifers in the
bowels of the earth to dry up and
condense
and so the land sinks